youth unemployment does pose a huge
problem to Europe I mean countries like
Greece Spain have a unemployment youth
unemployment rates over fifty percent
Italy over thirty percent but we as a
politician we have to give an open
perspective to people so what we need to
do our are two things first of all come
back to levels of growth and that you
can only do true thanks to intelligent
policies that means budgetary orthodoxy
yes but at the same time create
platforms of growth and growth you can
get by opening up markets making Europe
clearly function as a as a as a true
market and at the same time I think we
should think of advancing mobility in
Europe for youngsters to have a future
Portuguese young our countries because
we have a lot of vacancies so you should
stimulate mobility within Europe and at
the same time guarantee you're being
social protection for those people so
that youngsters young people can see
themselves not only as Nationals but in
the first place as true Europeans
therefore we need more Europe more
European solidarity and more European
social protection